I'm telling you, I saw that cat do stuff for soldiers.
Kids who'd been abused Haitians after storms.
Yeah. Sometimes the, uh, the, uh, in the ma the way that doesn't matter,
the topical stuff, I sometimes find him equally ill at ease as I am,
but walking the walk and that cat gave a lot of money to a lot of
people.
Hits with you, because I want to, I want to do sort of where you're at now,
but so when you then start doing O'Reilly and then suddenly people are going,
wait a minute, this is the SNL weekend update guy.
He's like this sort of like hip cool lib kinda.
For cool, or is not hip and cool. I was the same.
But, but the optics of it now suddenly, wait a minute, this doesn't make sense.
He was on SNL and now he's on evil Fox news. I'm just saying, you know,
this is not my opinion. This is just sort of like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But did you fear that at all? Or, or even none of it.
Listen, man, that was on the number one rated show on cable.
I think bill for 20 years, um, I was doing six minutes a week.
It was a beautiful gig. We'd go out on the road once a week or once a month.
We'd sell 10,000 seat crazy. Can you believe that? Could he believe it?
We definitely are a one plus one equals three thing because on my own,
I'd probably at that point draw too. I don't know what Billy was drawn,
but probably two, but you put us together in the mutton. Jeff of it.
It always reminded me of that scene in the Chaplin movie,
not saying we were a chaplain asked for Charlie,
puts his foot behind his leg and kicks the guy who is a work in the border guard
or the guy at LSI and kicks him in the butt. I was doing that to around.
And the key moment in that relationship was when, uh,
I told bill you're like a big mic beat cop, Irish meat beat cop,
where you're spinning that stick. Everybody's scared shitless. See you.
And I'm going to call you get Billy instead of bill.
And that Y was a great move because all of a sudden the, uh,
the power, the, the monolith as being poked fun at, by the,
the mutton Jeff Guy. And, uh, it was, it was cool.
That's why it worked together is because I could make him laugh,
not an unguarded laugh periodically, and I could poke fun at him.
I could call him Billy. I could wear shorts on his show, which, you know,
I put my leg up and he's like, do you know, not have all that work. And now.
A lot of those hits from home.
Did you have a home situation or were you going into a Fox affiliate or
something?
I went over to this place called the Rubin studios. I, uh, I, uh,
I think we did it up at Santa Barbara and another studio.
We're always on a split screen.
It was so funny until we started going on the road.
People would say you and bill, like, we're hoping Crosby is I, you know,
I've met her twice. We're always on a split screen, but over the years,
I'll tell you what, I'm a relatively ilities, uh,
uh, socially. I don't know what that is. I don't wanna make it precious bill.
I think if you could watch them over the years.
Cause off-camera, you seem exactly the same to me where no,
but there's plenty of comics. I know exactly what you're talking about.
There's a lot of comics that are weird, have eye contact stuff.
Don't want to touch anybody. And then the second, you know,
the camera goes on and bam, they're they're there,
but I don't from the little bit, we just did our thing. I didn't catch it.
Well, I,
I do know that I don't go to a lot of social events and stuff like that.
When I'm working, I have, I meet a hail fellow, well met.
I like to say hi and be normal. I'm going to cat's place,
but I'm not a real social guy. And he isn't either.
So when you put the two of us together, uh,
I was enamored of that part over a rally.
And I sometimes didn't understand his brusque manner. And I sometimes thought,
why is he beating his drum to that degree when I'd watch him on the show and
bill, if you're seeing this, I I'm not, you know, uh,
I I'm telling you, I saw that cat do stuff for soldiers.
Kids who'd been abused Haitians after storms.
Yeah. Sometimes the, uh, the, uh, in the ma the way that doesn't matter,
the topical stuff, I sometimes find him equally ill at ease as I am,
but walking the walk and that cat gave a lot of money to a lot of
people. And I don't know his personal life. You know, people say whatever I go,
do you really think, Oh, okay. So that's, that's my relationship with O'Reilly.
I'm going to call him and talk about dating or whatever the hell is going on.
It's not my life with him.
We went out on the road and I saw him do a lot of good things for a lot of
people. And guess what?
I felt no need to know to probe the underbelly of bill a rally or find out what
really makes him tick. And he felt no need to find out that being said,
I did seem to do enough things over the years that I find him an honorable man.
Yeah.
What do you think about the way that we take out people these days?
You don't have to make it about him specifically, but just generally, you know,
now Chris Matthews went out and it's just like this endless cascade of we're
just going to build people up.
Crush. It gets worse. You know,
imagine like Twitter during Dickensian, England. I don't know if
you listen, the rules are clear.
It's not worse than it's ever been. That's what everyone says every day.
It's worse than it's ever been.
I think the way that it'll turn this. Yeah, it might be.
But I think the way it'll turn,
this is everybody who's in the public eye should get up to a joke.
A witticism a pithy revelation and stop it down themselves
and look at the camera and say, I have something here,
but I'm going to stay up because I understand the new rules and have that happen
ad nauseum for a few years.
And I relate to people how crazy and our post store welling.
And it's gotten as far as jokes, dialogue, throwaways, cruelty,
indeed. Humans are cruel once in a while. Uh, you know,
the fact that that's all neutered down now,
I think people should be reminded that we're missing some of the texture of life
walking around, like we're in Logan's or something, you know, it's, uh,
I don't think it will change for a while because to me it's a,
the Lord of the flies.
And right now the uptight people have the conch and they're the ones that are
going to speak. And therefore,
if I'm sitting there and I get to a point in a joke where I go, this,
this puts me, uh, where I have to talk to people who I disagree with,
about how bad I am. I just, I stopped off at a jail. No,
I'm not going to say it. I've tackled myself here.
And if enough of that happens, people are going to start saying, Hey,
I'm sick of this.
Have a bunch that you just wouldn't tell anymore. Like,
like an old favorite that you're just.
Yeah. And it's, it's easy. Listen, when I used to be on network television,
they told you not to swear. I find that easy. Not to swear when I'm in Vegas.
I find that easy to say, when I'm here. I don't know what the rules are here.
You'll bleep them. No, we don't believe it. Yeah.
I don't even want you to cancel it right now. Think about it.
But I am saying that, uh, yes.
Uh, and not so much at this point, it all my career will be taken.
I don't care about that.
I care about having to spend time reacting to Nimrods,
who quite frankly think second guessing is creativity. It isn't.
I like being with creative people.
I like being with people who say things occasionally I'll believe you said that.
And, uh, I don't think it's over then.
And I listen to the human. The human fray is kickoff. It is.
It's like, well, where was it written that you never gave me here?
Anything that falls on your, you know,
feel you in your ear and you'll disagree with, I wouldn't want,
I don't want to lead that life.
So therefore I'll stop myself just because I think Christ I,
who needs the bring down of some white kid telling me how I've ruined his day.
Yeah. You know, I used to do, if there's some old,
my old stand-up tapes are right there.
And I used to do a joke way back when that I used to say the N word and it was
not to be racist in any way. It was actually a stupid,
silly transformers reference that I was imitating a transformer.
And I would say it would always get a huge laugh, huge laugh.
I would close with it sometimes.
And then one night I was on stage at Gotham comedy club on 24th.
And the audience kind of turned on me.
This is like maybe 2004 or something like that.
And I remember thinking I'm putting that one away and I never did it again.
I never, I never liked that feeling, but I was just like.
Yeah,
this is where you want to do a Nantucket sleigh ride with a bit where they ride
it to the bottom. Yeah. It doesn't interest me. I'm out there.
The police people, I like to get labs. And at some point,
if I have an opinion and I feel it's worth it, uh, I'll push it in.
Even if it draws Iyer.
But there are other times I think this isn't good enough to let this all this,
uh, agitate into my life. That's nerve and drags tires. So yeah. You know,
it's so precious to me that we sit down every day and 10 times a day,
somebody has to get themselves back and supine.
And I remember when, uh,
years ago there was a cat who is the general manager for the Los Angeles Dodgers
outcome panelists. Do you remember him? I'm Ted. Uh, I was here,
but here he goes on Ted Koppel one night and he says something that's like from
another generation racially and he's dead. You dead.
He's he's got to go supplicate for Sharpton, you know, all,
all that silly game. And, uh, cause,
cause sharpen so righteous. Yeah. Yeah. And I remember thinking, you know,
when Jackie Robinson first came up and he goes to Montreal and the Dodgers he's
playing minor league baseball and they got to assign somebody to go out with a
cat and you know, uh, right wing, man, I think Campanis is right there.
I mean, when it came to real life,
he was there and then later he says something brutish from a dead day,
gone by and he's over. And I remember thinking, Oh,
this is so tedious. You know, that's the smartest thing Eric Holder ever said.
Although I think he backed back, ended into,
I don't even think he meant it the way I took it. When he said we're cowards,
we don't even have chats about things anymore. Uh, racial relations, indeed.
We don't. And guess what you're going to, you want to be the first guy in
early. You want to be over this afternoon,
trying to make some sort of lucid nuanced comment about interactions
between human beings of different colors.
You don't want to be the first guy and you're done.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling, you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here to get notified of all future videos.
Be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.